kulagin happens was president when the
hundred and fiftieth anniversary of the
Declaration of Independence rolled
around that was in 1926 and he gave many
beautiful speeches he was a very
talented man and this may be his best
speech and I'm going to read to you what
he says about the Declaration because
it's it's interesting because so much of
it constitutes a direct answer to the
claims of the progressive movement which
are raging at the time of course
Coolidge succeeded after Harding was
killed Woodrow Wilson is President of
the United States he was answering the
Wilson administration with the
Declaration of Independence a very
interesting thing that happened in
history here's a paragraph from the
speech by the way and it's in our reader
and I urge you to read it the whole
thing is very worth knowing
he writes it's about three-quarters of
the way through the speech about the
Declaration there is a finality that is
exceedingly restful you see think of
that word restful progress constant
movement always forward
but the declaration says Coolidge is
restful it doesn't have to go anywhere